welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss in one division's finale revealed
that evan peters pietro aka fietro is
actually
a ralph boner aspiring actor chill dude
and resident of west view new jersey
whose home was overtaken by the witch
agatha hartness controlling him with a
necklace mcconaughey would definitely
dig
he is the husband ralph oft mentioned by
agnes throughout the series one of
vision's apparently given us the kind of
answers we'd find graffitied on the wall
of a high school boys bathroom
pietro's chode crossed out boner and
that circled
i boned his mom and then right under
that is that you magneto
now many fans had much higher hopes for
evan peters who of course played
quicksilver in the fox x-men franchise
that his cameo might be a
sign of a bigger multiverse crossover
but if he is
just some dude then why cast evan peters
at all in this role why not cast anybody
else
well i started to answer this question
after episode 6 but now that the finale
has given us some firm answers
along with some huge revelations that
were just revealed in an interview by
the series director
it's now pretty clear what marvel
intended by casting evan peters and
wandavision but more importantly what
that confirms about their actual plan
for mutants and
x-men in the next upcoming marvel titles
this year but before i continue this
video is sponsored by darkfire heroes
collect upgrade and play as a whole host
of powerful heroes look at how many
awesome ones there are to choose from
darkfire heroes the
fun free to play mobile rpg that you can
download from the link in this video's
description
the one division finale confirmed that
evan peter's character's name is ralph
foner
monica learns this from two hard pieces
of evidence meaning that marvel's not
kidding around here they gave us double
evidence first a water bill
mailed to him and then an actor's
headshot with his face and name
as a comedian in la who has printed
several of these just to have him stack
up in the trunk of my car
i found this triggering but this water
bill goes back
several months though it looks like the
date on it is october 21st 2020
technically the date of the outside
world in the mcu is october or november
2023
though currently on the inside of the
hex it's supposed to be 2013
but also at least part of this
particular house is its own kind of hex
proof zone
by the way folks generally movie and tv
prop designers make these dates on
documents around when the content is
expected to release
unless a director or writer comes to
them to tell them hey this printed date
is actually going to be in focus in
close up in the frame so make sure it's
this
now you could argue that ralph boner was
just this guy's name
in the hex the way herb was the hex name
of john collins
dottie is the hex name of sarah et
cetera fair but we know
parts of this house exist separate from
wanda's hex
overall this dwelling seems more under
agatha's spell than wandas and this
water bill seems like an element from
the outside world anyway because
why would wanda warp paperwork to the
year 2020
in an otherwise 2013 era and if wanda
warped her
neighbor into a false identity ralph
boner when he walked through her door
why wouldn't she immediately just be
like no no you're not pietro
you're my neighbor ralph the actor folks
the logical context of this scene any
prop detail over sights aside is that
evan peters is just some dude who lived
in this town the implication of this is
that ralph has lived in this house for a
while and that agave
after wanda began the hex intruded upon
ralph so that
she could be wanda's next door neighbor
and then she used her magic to turn the
basement of this house into this witch
dungeon
and that must also include planting
those purple vines that snake down into
the basement which i still think could
be the magical herb the wundegor
everbloom just because they left agatha
alive and they're probably going to
revisit her at some point in the mcu
i don't think ralph is jimmy woo's
missing witness that he mentioned in
episode 4. jimmy wu had relocated that
witness
to that town recently and according to
that water bill ralph has been
in this house for months if not years
and the bill is overdue which is
important because in witness protection
the government covers your basic living
expenses
also if ralph wasn't witness protection
there would be no way he could be a
working
actor with headshots you are prohibited
from any attention-grabbing activities
like freaking acting
and in episode 6 jimmy is in the room
when ralph is on the screens
and he doesn't at all react in a way
that suggests hey that's my guy
now some point to the name boner as a
joke jimmy wu might suggest
to which i would say no jimmy is a
freaking boy scout
his sense of humor is on par with ned
flanders naming someone boner is
something
eric hartman would do boner is more
likely a nod to mike siever's buddy
boner on growing pain this sitcom that
partly inspired the 80s sitcom ralph
first appeared and the show that spun
off just the 10 of us where director
matt shackman got his start along with
appearances in a bunch of 80s sitcoms
like growing pains
boner was a sitcom reference too wasn't
it because when growing pains
like there was a kid named or something
like that that's a reference to yeah i
was on growing pain so yeah
that's a reference to boner now how did
akva give ralph super speed well agave's
goal with presenting ralph as pietro was
to trick wanda into thinking he was her
speedster brother
agatha said wanda was so crippled by
self-doubt that she believed it and
remember as a witch agave can do all
kinds of stuff she can fly
teleport use telekinesis wanda can move
super fast she sneaks up freaky fast
so for agatha imbuing super speed on her
puppet is just an extension of the many
things she can do so
after all this was casting evan peters
just some kind of meta joke then
kevin feige had to know what this would
mean to fans now we know the show
creators were aware because
when peters first appeared disney plus
audio commentary described him as quote
the version of pietro from the x-men
films
now feige recently said that evan peters
was just another way that certain people
meaning agatha were messing with wanda
and peters himself recently told fans i
know you have a lot of questions
as do i i just want to say dude i'm such
a huge fan of the marvel universe
it was so cool to come over there and
hang out with all those guys
that was uh that was freaking awesome
but before we continue oh
what is this
well this is the amazing free to play
mobile rpg
dark fire heroes and it is completely
free download it now via the link in the
description of this video
collect upgrade and play as a whole host
of powerful heroes look at how many
awesome ones there are to choose from
battle your way through armies of deadly
monsters and
ghouls in this non-stop real-time
strategic rpg that is changing the way
rpgs are played on mobile forever face
tough bosses and test your skills and
get awesome rewards for defeating them
there is a whole new adventure waiting
for you to explore in darkfire heroes
battle your friends in the real time pvp
arena and claim your title as the true
dark fire hero
if you download it now for free in the
description below you will receive a
special new player welcome bonus
including an adventure chest on your
very first day look at that i got a
little reward just coins
coins this is the game changer we've all
been waiting for choose your hero and
slay the bad guys
darkfire hero is completely free on
android and ios
download darkfire heroes now from the
link in the description and receive a
special reward i'll see you
on the battlefield my friends so matt
shackman told kevin smith and mark
bernard on their fat man beyond show
that when it comes to evan peters they
could have had aaron taylor johnson
pietro at the door
but that they had already resurrected
one loved one for wanda and that fake
pietro would be a more
interesting reflection of wanda's grief
which is what the show is really all
about
so what's more interesting like what
grief does to us that we're a lot that
we
that allows us to accept a face that is
unfamiliar to us
um and to roll with that as unnerving as
it may seem
because one again this is this is
bargaining right here we are in the
stages of death
stages and grief and yes jackman
admitted that this was a bit of plane
with expectations with a meta sitcom
joke the way actors will sometimes just
get recast between episodes with no
explanation
matt schachman said that casting evan
peters was decided early in development
which would have been some time in the
first half of 2019 now that was back
when marvel studios expected to release
one division
fourth in their phase four lineup black
widow in may 2020
then the falcon winner soldier in fall
2020 then the eternals in november 2020
and then one division in early 2021
so wandavision went from being a quirky
fourth in line risk taker to
the all eyes on them opening act air to
end game
expected to set all the rules and answer
all the questions
so cast in evan peters which was a joke
that was baked in a year and a half
before
would now be interpreted as a major clue
for marvel's future future future
so i don't think kevin feige would sow
that confusion on purpose
so i think that tells us that one of
marvel's titles that were originally
intended to precede one division
black widow the falcon of the winter
soldier or eternals
is going to shed light on how mutants
are actually coming into the mcu
so that viewers would have been more
likely to see evan peters as just a joke
instead of a kind of signal of something
now i have talked about the various ways
the mutants could come in and those
other titles
black widow could establish one of red
guardian's prison cellmates as
a mutant like a peter rasputin colossus
the falcon of the winter soldier is
confirmed to visit magipore a setting
linked with wolverine in the comics but
my money is on eternals a film that
promises to explain the origins of the
marvel universe from ancient times the
god-like celestials the war between the
eternals and the deviants
and a part of that whole creation
mythology is mutant-kind
which started in ancient egypt with in
sabaner
aka apocalypse if eternals is going to
explain how mutant kind started on earth
it's also got to explain how mutankind
began
now i doubt that means we'll meet all
the x-men in eternals but it could very
likely give us a backstory of
how they exist in the present mcu and i
think that story was
intended to be the narrative we went
into one division with so that when evan
peters shows up the fans would be like
what but then when he's revealed to be a
boner we would just laugh it off with
the comfort of knowing what feige's
actual mutant plan was gonna be
so yeah it does sound like evan peters
was intended to just be a fun meta joke
a bit of stunt casting for fans of the
x-men films not meant to be taken
seriously
and now it looks like marvel's trying to
come up with a way to explain that
that'll keep fans on their side and it
is hard to blame kovid and say
we wanted to give you something that was
completed and ready to release when at
the same time as of this moment they are
still refusing to release black widow on
disney plus because it's always
about money folks so why evan peters in
particular well
a goofy meta joke dragged from the late
slot to the cold open
coveted rescheduling stubbornness over
black widow and
fans like you and me who love stuff way
too much hey but the good news is
mutants are still coming and they will
have no idea what dark phoenix was
but if that's not enough for you matt
shackman left us with this reassuring
message
and i what i would say to the to the
marvel fan who's a little disappointed
that
the x-men didn't show up or the
multiverse didn't show up um
clearly right there is that they're
coming you know they're coming right
you've got a movie called multiverse of
madness you've got
mutants announced at comic-con a year
and a half ago
like they're coming support this channel
by checking out one of our many great
merch options at newrockstarsmerch.com
follow me on instagram and twitter avos
follow me rockstar subscribe to
rockstars for everything marvel thanks
for watching
boner i i vote it's funny to say
[Music]
you